[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez aujourd'hui j'ai envie de me
faire encore plus plaisir que d'habitude
en vous parlant de théories sur la saga
final fantasy mon saga en or et qui est
gravé en moi comme la meilleure série de
jeux vidéo au monde
je suis un fan de la saga et il est
inutile de le cacher que ce soit
musicalement ou scénaristiquement final
fantasy me transcende
et j'aimerais vous proposez donc trois
théorie originale et que je trouve très
intéressante
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est une petite théorie très peu connue
du net
et vu que j'étais pas mal à fond sur
final fantasy xii zodiac edge ces
derniers temps je souhaitais absolument
vous en parler pour bien vous expliquer
final fantasy xii zodiac edge est un
ramasseur ps 4 de final fantasy xii sur
ps2 les graphismes les musiques les
permis tout a été modifié et comme dans
le jeu d'origine larmes de base la plus
puissante était là lance du zodiaque
avec 152 dégâts de base
elle fut l' arme la plus puissante sur
ps2 et je précise bien sûr le terme
elle fut il faut savoir que dans final
fantasy xii pour que votre personnage
puisse s'équiper d'une arme il lui faut
le permis qui va avec cependant un
personnage ne peut accéder qu'à
seulement deux grilles de permis par
exemple - vannes possède les grilles m
daste qui peut s'équiper de lens par
exemple et la grille chevallier qui peut
s'équiper dp à une voire deux mains et
de boucliers néanmoins ce dernier ne
pourra en aucun cas posséder de bâton
d'agde ou arc du moins normalement car
le sujet de la théorie et la fameuse
moraine dont nous allons parler
cette dernière est la meilleure arme du
jeu de l'opus zodiac edge et ne figurait
pas dans le jeu d'origine
c'est un arc possédant plus de 224 de
dégâts avec 75 de parade soit 2 contres
pour les attaques ennemies
ce qui est juste phénoménale et
démesurée de plus cette arme
contrairement à ce que je vous
expliquais avec vannes c'est qu'elle ne
figure dans aucun permis donc elle peut
être équipée par n'importe qui la
théorie est donc que cette arme était
destiné aux développeurs et c'est assez
marrant de voir que certains joueurs ont
réussi à y accéder
cette arme ne figure dans aucune grille
de permis déjà ce n'est pas normal
elle possède 74 dégâts d'attac de plus
que la meilleure arme du jeu de base ce
qui est totalement démesurée
avec 75 de parade ce qui est largement
meilleur que n'importe quel bouclier
alors que c'est seulement un arc mais
vous allez me demander comment peut-on
accéder à cette arme est bien
normalement nous ne pouvons pas puisque
elle s'acquiert de façon très étrange en
manipulant la rng du jeu là rng pour
ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas réellement
le terme c'est en gros la composante à
l'aiea
d'un jeu en gros vous allez faire telle
ou telle action pour maximiser vos
chances voire à coup sûr obtenir quelque
chose qui s'obtient avec de la chance
cette arme est cachée sur la navette de
croisière provenant de rabanne astres et
allant jusqu'aux faubourgs donne albina
c'est un quoi qui est très peu utilisé
par les joueurs et cela expliquerait
déjà pourquoi elle se positionnerait ici
le coffre contenant cette arme est
d'ailleurs invisible et apparaît
seulement si la rn10 du jeu est
manipulée nous n'avons pas le droit
d'avoir accès à cette arme à la base
j'ai personnellement essayé et j'ai pas
réussi
évidemment c'est assez complexe et la
théorie serait donc que cette arme était
destiné aux développeurs du jeu pour
faciliter les combats notamment certains
boss plutôt compliqué et qu'ils auraient
oublié de complètement effacé sept armes
du jeu
néanmoins je suis dans le doute
concernant un éventuel oublie ff12 le
jeu d'origine sur ps2 était déjà
constitué d'éléments cacher un point que
l'on était obligé de regarder une soluce
pour le trouver ou avoir énormément de
chance on peut prendre l'exemple du
vendeur caché dans la nécropole de nabû
10 les développeurs auraient pu laisser
cette arme dans le jeu pour que certains
joueurs la trouve
mais avec énormément de chance même si
celle ci est faussé par la rn j'ai
manipulé
après tout c'est la meilleure arme du
jeu est de très loin
normal qu'elle soit dur à obtenir
très pris
m
[Musique]
pour cette seconde théorie j'aimerais
vous parler de l'un de mes boss préféré
du monde du jeu vidéo
gilgamesh gilgamesh apparaît pour la
première fois dans final fantasy 5 et
est inspire d'ex ds le boss final de cet
opus cependant gilgamesh est un guerrier
très puissant qui se prend en finale
d'affection pour le groupe dayraut de
l'épisode et en particulier bartz le
héros principal de final fantasy 5
exdeath ayant remarqué cette liaison et
ses défaites face au groupe
il décide donc de l'envoyer dans une
autre dimension pour le punir
mais le groupe de héros ira aussi dans
cette dimension afin de trouver exdeath
et le vaincre cependant sur le chemin
les héros devront faire face un des
lieutenants d'ex des sceaux qu'est le
combat tendra très mal c'est alors que
gilgamesh apparaîtra pour défaire le
lieutenant se sacrifiant et affirmant
avant sa disparition avoir toujours rêvé
de combattre barde dans les règles de
l'art une dernière fois
tout laisse croire que gilgamesh est
donc mort en se sacrifiant mais la chose
intrigante et qu'il réapparaît dans un
très très grand nombre de final fantasy
suite à l'opus 5 final fantasy 5 joue
d'ailleurs beaucoup sur les dimensions
et ilga mèche en se sacrifiant serait
donc tombée dans le vortex l'envoyant
donc dans d'autres dimensions
c'est pourquoi il apparaîtrait dans
d'autres final fantasy gilgamesh et
passionnés par les armes de légende et
respecte énormément ses ennemis quand
ils sont de valeur lydia mèche dans les
autres final fantasy est toujours à la
recherche de nouvelles armes
c'est pourquoi dans l'opus 12 on le voit
avec par exemple les paies de cloud ou
la gueule blade de squall on pourrait
penser à un easter egg mais dans la
théorie gilgamesh ce serait dégoter ses
armes après ses aventures dans chaque
dimension avant d'arriver à l'opus 12
toujours à la recherche de combat il
pourrait aussi s'allier à vous
respectant votre maîtrise on peut
prendre l'exemple de final fantasy 8 où
ce dernier apparaît pour rendre la place
dos d'un vaincu par cypher ou bien dans
final fantasy xii revenant wings
où il rejoindra le groupe de vannes
après avoir été vaincu 2 3 fois par le
passé un peu comme avec le groupe de
barnes auquel gilgamesh souhaitez
participer à leur aventure
gilgamesh voyagerait donc par les
dimensions et le temps pour trouver de
nouvelles armes et surtout pour réaliser
son but ultime
retrouvez bartz et se battre contre lui
une dernière fois ainsi que retrouver
son monde natal
quelques éléments peuvent aider à cette
théorie d'ailleurs il ya mèche est à la
base un samouraï un guerrier si puissant
provenant du clan genji qu'il aurait le
droit de porter les célèbres équipements
genji équipements propres à gilgamesh et
qu'on peut lui voler dans final fantasy
xii ou retrouver dans final fantasy 15
peut-être un passage dans ce dernier
dans le gouffre des os cela peut être
une réelle suppositions d'ailleurs nous
le retrouvons une fois de plus dans ff
15 ce dernier est là pour tester les
prochains bouclier du roi des guerriers
comme gladius formés pour protéger le
roi d'une gamme s étend à guerrier
surpuissant toujours à la recherche de
combat ce serait attribué cette mission
pour justement combattre les guerriers
de valeur gilgamesh n'est pas quelqu'un
de mauvais loin de là
il est seulement à la recherche d'armes
et de guerriers de valeur c'est pourquoi
chaque combat contre lui peu importe le
ff est un combat épique
il rejoindra à votre cause tout dépend
du ff notamment grâce à vos compétences
de valeur et le respect qu'il vous
attribue jusqu'au jour où peut-être
retrouvera-t-il le chemin de la maison
et son rival depuis toujours
bartz avec qui ils partageraient un
dernier combat dans les règles de l'art
gilgamesh est un personnage tellement
intéressant de l'univers final fantasy
que j'aimerais un jour vous faire une
vidéo rien que sur lui pour tout savoir
sur ce dernier
cette théorie m'a énormément inspiré et
pourrait donner lieu à deux trois vidéos
que je souhaite réellement vous faire il
ya mèche le voyage dans le temps
d'autres vidéos sur final fantasy
bref cette saga est une réelle passion
[Musique]
passionné par le voyage dans le temps
j'aimerais qu'on continue dans ce sujet
avec mon opus préféré de la saga final
fantasy 8
mais pour cela je vais devoir entrer
dans l'univers étendu du jeu
malheureusement peu connu par les
joueurs mais que les passionnés ont
accès via les livres à l'origine de
final fantasy 8 existait un être divin
il était connu sous le nom de in il
était un être si puissant que ces
pouvoirs lui permirent de façonner le
monde cependant ils commencent à se
lasser de cette activité et décida donc
de déléguer la poursuite de son oeuvre à
des êtres inférieurs à lui qu'il aurait
créé de ses mains les hommes il les
considère d'ailleurs comme des outils je
vais essayer d'abréger sinon je vais
devoir vous raconter toute l'histoire de
ff8 et ce n'est pas quand vie m'empêche
mais nous avons une vidéo à faire in
s'exila pour se reposer cependant les
hommes se retrouvant seul sur l'habitat
créé par l'être divin décidèrent donc de
devenir leur propre maître et donc
remodeler le monde à leur goût ce qui
n'a pas réellement plu à in le jour de
son réveil qui décida donc de tuer un
très grand nombre de ces outils
ce qui créa une énorme rancoeur chez les
hommes qui avaient soif de vengeance il
fut affaibli par cette rébellion à cause
du grand nombre d'hommes il fit alors
une négociation avec les hommes qui
étaient en vérité à un mauvais tour de
l'être divin avant de soudainement
disparaître laissant les hommes donc se
diviser entre eux pour un pseudo
morceaux de pouvoir qui n'était qu'un
mensonge dean lors de leurs négociations
je serais heureux de vous raconter tout
ça en détail mais peut-être dans une
vidéo consacré à final fantasy 8 si vous
le désirez a vous de me dire dans les
commentaires
bref mais du coup avant de disparaître
et d'être reconnue que par d'anciennes
légendes ligne d les gars sont réels
pouvoirs dans le corps de femme ce qui
crée à l'héritage des sorcières j'aime
enrichir votre culture générale de final
fantasy
maintenant si nous revenons dans le
présent de final fantasy 8 nous savons
qu'une seule et même sorcière existe
dans le monde avant que sa vie ne
s'achève au moment de sa mort cette
dernière doit transmettre ses pouvoirs à
une autre femme qui deviendra donc la
nouvelle sorcière qui à son tour etc etc
cela s'appelle l'héritage des sorcières
originellement le pouvoir dean l'être
divin
maintenant suite à cet aparté rentrons
dans le vif de la
oui à l'aube du cd 4 de final fantasy 8
nos héros lance la compression temporel
à la poursuite du multimédia ces
derniers cherchent à sortir du futur
pour justement la terrasse est elle qui
veut fusionner avec passé présent et
avenir pour devenir le seul être
omnipotent et omniscient afin d'éviter
son terrible destin qu'un très grand
site reviendra là dessus
néanmoins lors du voyage de nos héros
dans la compression temporel ces
derniers sont face à des sortes de
sorcière qu'ils devront abattre pour
avancer mais qui sont ces sorcières d'où
viennent tél
pourquoi sont-elles ici à la base nous
pourrions penser que ce sont des sortes
de monstres envoyé par ultimes essais
dans le tunnel de la compression
temporelle pour ralentir nos héros ce
qui reste louable mais bizarrement il
logique
intéressons nous donc au peu d'infos que
nous avons dans l'ultime anja il est dit
que ces sorcières viennent de l'au delà
dans la version française
en dehors du temps dans la version
américaine mais la plus intéressante et
plus proche du réel et la version
japonaise qui parle de générations
successives ces sorcières serait en
réalité les successeurs du présent d'où
sont parties nos héros étant donné que
nos héros par la compression temporel
voyage vers le futur pour défaire ultime
esiae affronterait donc les sorcières
attirés par la compression qui
succèderait donc à lino à la dernière
sorcière de son époque jusqu'à ultime et
sia la dernière sorcière de son époque
mais cela reste tout de même quelque
chose de flou car si squall des faits
avec ses alliés ses sorcières cela veut
dire que le destin de toutes les
sorcières étaient donc de mourir face au
cid tout comme ultime et sia d'ailleurs
pour moi à l'agro sorciers en forme de
serpent que noah héros affronte avant de
finir la compression pourrait être une
sorte de sorcière ultime de son époque
comme adèle auparavant ou ultime et sia
dans le futur après tout nous avons la
preuve que les sites combat toujours les
sorcières à travers les âges avec les
sites blanc mort devant le château
d'ultimedia erreur scénaristique ou bien
réel sorcières nous pouvons adéquatement
supposer que ce col affrontent les
sorcières à travers les âges à cause de
la compression temporel mais rappelez
vous que cela n'a jamais été confirmée
par square enix
cependant la boucle temporelle créé par
ultime et ciani nos héros qui permet
donc l ultime et sia de transmettre ses
pouvoirs à edéa et donc linoa d'être la
dernière sorcière du présent suite à
leur combat final face à la sorcière du
futur changerait tel le destin de ces
sorciers remorque lors du combat contre
ce col dans la compression temporel
enfin bref j'ai peut-être dit énormément
de conneries mais la question du voyage
dans le temps le destin et cetera est
réellement quelque chose de passionnant
je suis un réel passionné de final
fantasy et dès que je pourrais nous
referons des théories sur cette saga
mythique à mes yeux
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus et qui partageront la vidéo
c'était hard rock et que le line up soit
avec vous
[Musique]